in ostdeutschland auch in thüringen ganz
besonders in sachsen aber eben auch in
thüringen hat die cdu desaster erlebt
hat ja wir haben gestern die wahlkreis
karte gesehen sachsen vor allem aber
eben auch thüringen sind blau geworden
und blau bedeutet afd trägt armin
laschet die schuld daran
die schuld trägt die gesamtpartei die
cdu hatte im osten nicht die themen
angesprochen die die sorgen der leute
sind das muss aufgearbeitet werden das
ist ein katastrophales ergebnis und am
ende ist es viele gründe und sicherlich
ist das auch eine frage
spitzenkandidaten aber es ist eine
gesamtpartei die die verantwortung trägt
dass die union
der gesamtpartei aber dennoch war armin
laschet der falsche kandidat um die
wähler im osten abzuholen
es wird ernster weise niemand bezweifeln
dass der spitzenkandidat die zum osten
kein zugpferd gewesen ist besonders auch
das thema corona hat spätestens seit der
bundesgrenze zu massiven verärgerung in
der wählerschaft geführt es ging auch um
die frage hat der osten im wahlkampf
überhaupt eine rolle gespielt da haben
sich viele gewundert dass da über die
köpfe hinweg gesprochen worden ist und
am ende merkt man eben auch dass
vielfach so diese berlin-mitte themen
hier im ländlichen raum nicht so richtig
angekommen sind die wähler die die union
wählen die erwarten ja dass ihr kleiner
wohlstand gesichert wird und diese
themen haben wir gar nicht angesprochen
man kann es nicht anders sagen wer die
dürfe und die kleinen städte verliert
verliert am ende auch das land also
armin laschet hat auch auf diese
berlin-mitte themen gesetzt was hinter
diese berlin-mitte themen
es ist immer die frage im vordergrund zu
stellen ja klimawandel frage dass das
natürlich teuer wird für die leute nur
wissen sie wenn wir mittlerweile bei
benzinpreisen bald auf zwei euro
zusteuern und wir leute in thüringen
haben die beide auf ihr auto angewiesen
sind dann kostet das natürlich normale
familien oder wenn es um die frage geht
und digitalisierung auch im ländlichen
raum als die menschen das gefühl dass
sie abgegangen werden und das hat die
post eine große rolle gespielt weil sie
mir das gefühl hat und es wird über ihre
köpfe hinweg lebensstil propagiert
während ihrer ist
mit welchen themen hätte man im osten
punkten müssen ganz zwingend in diesem
wahlkampf
ich glaube vordergrund hätte erstmal
bezahlbares leben stehen müssen nämlich
die frage was eine belastung
mittlerweile für auf die leute zu kommen
ihnen wurde die ölheizung genommen die
ganzen rohstoffpreisen teurer geworden
die handwerker ächzen unter der frage
was das benzin für sie kostet was für
bürokratiekosten für sie letztlich auch
unterwegs sind das sind alles themen die
im vordergrund gestanden hätten aber
fallen lebensnahe themen greifbares wir
haben plakatiert wir wollen den krieg
klimaneutrales industrieland sein diese
innere anspruch ist richtig aber was
dahinter sich verbirgt für die menschen
war einfach nicht greifbar war nicht
empathisch und ich denke das ist etwas
was durchaus auch eine rolle gespielt
hat in diesem wahlkampf und andere
themen werden logischerweise auch
gewesen renten gerechtigkeit
lohngerechtigkeit wir sind im
dreißigsten jahr der deutschen einheit
noch darüber hinaus und trotzdem haben
wir unterschiedliche löhne das können
sie niemandem mehr erklären und das ist
auch ein thema was eine cdu als partei
der einheit adressieren muss noch mal
zurück zur armin laschet da waren die
umfragen ja schon vor der wahl eindeutig
den wollten die deutschen eindeutig
nicht zum kanzler haben die überwiegende
mehrheit nicht genau so war das ergebnis
auch genauso auch die nachwahlbefragung
die umfragen danach zwar ganz klar die
deutschen wollten diesen mann nicht er
hat nicht gezogen sollte armin laschet
jetzt die union weiter in die zukunft
führen
ich halte nichts davon dass man
irgendwie immer so einzelne leute
herausgreift und sie wäscht die partei
gewinnt zusammen sie verliert zusammen
klar ist dass er im wahlkampf jetzt
nicht das zugpferd im osten gewesen ist
ja das habe ich schon gesagt herr vogt
ich aber nur den mann herausgegriffen
den sie
überlebensgroß auf die plakate gedruckt
haben das ist ja schon entscheiden
dessen kopf da drauf ist und die
menschen wollten ihn nicht deswegen ist
es doch für sie eine existenzielle frage
wen sie da nach vorne stellen wer ihre
nummer eins ist das ist nicht irgendwer
denen man sich da rauskriegt soll der
mann der wie gesagt überlebensgroß
überall in den städten zu sehen war
zumindest auf der zielgeraden ja
zumindest wir jetzt erstmal als partei
entschieden dass er die gespräche auch
notwendigerweise führen soll ich sehe
uns nicht im lied weil wir sind nicht
nummer eins aber wenn es so kommt das
eben auch grüne und fdp
gesprächsbereitschaft signalisieren dann
sollte das auch passieren und ich glaube
für diese gespräche haben da steht jetzt
erst mal ein auftrag was wir als partei
schonungslos analysieren müssen das
steht jetzt an und für mich steht im
vordergrund eine neue basis
verbundenheit das darf nicht einfach nur
eine analyse im bundesvorstand sein
sondern müssen alle mitglieder
mitgenommen werden und für uns im osten
gilt wir brauchen aus konferenz weil wo
alle ostdeutschen landesverbände
zusammen kommen und genau diesen druck
auf die bundespartei ausüben
[Musik]